[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme tous les matins chez au volant de
la voiture
j'écoute de la musique je suis pas très
réveillé le feu passe au rouge
une femme traverse devant moi elle me
ressemble
elle semble avoir mon âge ça pourrait
être ma soeur ma copine elle porte des
vêtements sombres
elle cache ses cheveux sous un bonnet
elle n'est pas trop maquillée un détail
m'attire elle traîne un petit chariot ou
ya pas de fruits et légumes dedans un
oreiller et une couverture dépassent
légèrement le feu passe au vert
je démarre pas on klaxonne
je réalise qu'elle est sdf
pourtant elle ne ressemble pas à une
clocharde à cet instant précis je me dis
et c'était moi un jour sur ce trottoir
parce qu'on est bien là si tout se joue
dans cette salle mais qui peut lever la
main et oser dire qu'il n'a pas pensé
que ça pourrait lui arriver un jour moi
j'ai peur et vous allez voir que j'ai
des raisons d'avoir peur le dernier
rapport de la fondation abbé-pierre
montrent que le nombre de sdf a augmenté
de 50% en 10 ans aujourd'hui 143 milles
personnes sont sans domicile fixe et les
femmes ne font pas exception
c'est juste une réalité sociale méconnu
elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses
elles seraient 7000 à paris pourtant
personne ne les voir personne ne les
remarque
elles sont invisibles
derrière ces chiffres froids et glaçant
il ya pourtant des visages
elle s'appelle martin myriam ou barbara
certaine aux vingt ans d'autres 60 et
tout avait une vie comme moi avant une
maison un travail un mari et pour
certaines des enfants si vous ne les
voyez pas ça normal elle se cache se
rendre transparents oublient leur
féminité passe des nuits à errer dans la
ville des jours qui se ressemblent sans
jamais vraiment savoir où aller alors où
sont elles
comment survivent tél moi je suis
réalisatrice depuis 15 ans je raconte le
monde à ma façon
l'adoption la maltraitance infantile les
bébé secoué un jour je suis policière la
brigade des mineurs
un autre infirmière à l'hôpital necker
il ya deux ans à ce fameux feux rouges
cette femme elle m'a donné envie d'aller
à la rencontre de celles qui avaient
perdu pied mais sans tomber dans la
caricature sans montrer des femmes
alcooliques ou des femmes qui souffrent
de troubles psychiatriques
je voulais montrer des femmes qui nous
ressemble celles qui sont sur le fil
celle qui s'accrochent encore des
combattantes celles qui croient encore à
ce qui peut nous caractérise et nous les
femmes
c'est à dire l'envié d'être jolie alors
je décide de mettre mon savoir faire à
leur service et je vais faire un
documentaire je vais les rendre digne
belle avant de montrer qu'elles sont sdf
pour permettre peut-être de changer
notre regard à tous mais comment faire
alors que j'ai pas eu envie de faire
comme d'habitude c'est à dire aller voir
des professionnels rencontrer des gens
pour qu'on m'explique comment faire un
soir je mets une doudoune un bonnet des
baskets j'enlève mes bijoux et je pars
dans les rues de paris à leur rencontre
comment leur parler les tutoyer les vous
voyez leur offrez un sandwich de
l'argent je suis mal à l'aise j'ai pas
trop comment m'y prendre
je passe des jours à me présenter salut
je m'appelle claire je devrais faire un
documentaire vous avez deux secondes à
m'accorder vous voulez prendre un café
avec moi on me regarde hyper bizarre on
se demande ce que je veux je me fais
jeter beaucoup et puis un soir c'est la
rencontre j'aperçois une fille au loin
sur le boulevard haussmann
helm attire comme un aimant c'est la
fille que je cherche
j'en suis sûr je lui tape sur l'épaule
elle se retourne elle me sourit elle
accepte de prendre un café avec moi elle
me balance sa vie elle s'appelle barbara
elle a 26 ans ça fait un an qu'elle vit
dans la rue elle a un look un peu
androgyne les yeux cernés
elle a quitté sa famille à avignon pour
une histoire d'amour elle se drogue
elle prend du crack elle dort dans le
parking des galeries lafayette au moins
8 elle fait la manche
la première fois elle me raconte qu'elle
avait monde qu'elle s'est cachée
derrière sa pancarte aujourd'hui son
discours est rodé elle pourra avoir des
aides
elle vit en moyenne avec 30 euros par
jour de la manche
elle se rend bien compte qu'elle est
dans un cercle infernal
elle sait pas comment faire pour s'en
sortir
j'ai passé cinq mois avec barbara j'en
ai rencontré beaucoup d'autres chacune
avec leur histoire
j'ai découvert un monde surréaliste hors
du temps comme un voyage lunaire dans
les rues de paris
j'ai partagé des moments de leur nuit
leurs jours aujourd'hui je sais je sais
où elle dort où elle mange
quels sont leurs besoins quels sont leur
plaisir j'ai aussi rencontré martine
martin à la cinquante six ans c'est une
rescapée elle en paraît dix de plus
parce que la rue ça abîme
martine elle me propose de passer une
journée ordinaire avec elle comme elle
dit ça démarre dans un centre
d'hébergement pour sans domicile fixe ou
une équipe de jeunes bénévoles donnent
un peu de leur temps gratuitement pour
s'occuper des pieds des sdf
quand je rentre dans la pièce une
dizaine de sdf qui sont en train de se
faire soigner
couper les ongles soignés les pieds je
suis partagé entre une envie de vomir
une envie de rire et quand je vois le
visage de martin je rigole plus du tout
je me rends compte à quel point ça lui
fait du bien de se faire dorloter couper
les ongles alors juste après je décide
de moi aussi lui faire du bien à martin
et je l'emmène prendre un café à peine
réchauffées
elle s'effondre de fatigue sur la table
autour de nous plaindre monde
indifférence totale parce que martin la
plupart du temps elle dort pas elles
passent la nuit dans des bus attendre
que ça passe
elle se réchauffe elle m'explique que
les chauffeurs sont conciliants et
qu'elle se sent en sécurité parce que la
plupart des femmes sdf comme martin
elles vont pas dans le métro dans le
métro on s'enfonce on perd ses repères
c'est le même bruit la même température
les mêmes odeurs alors la plupart du
temps ces femmes elles dans des cages
d'escalier ou dans des parkings
souterrains
martin allemand mais non soir près de la
gare montparnasse dormir dans un parking
elle enlève son sac à dos le pose pour
s'en servir d'oreillers et s'allonge en
m'expliquant qu'elle va dormir comme ça
toute la nuit sans enlever ses
chaussures ni ses vêtements je m'étais
imaginé cette scène et pourtant je suis
saisi par l'horreur pourquoi ces femmes
dorment dans des parkings souterrains
parce qu'à paris y a qu une seule ligne
pour trouver alice et celle du 115 le
samu social un standard saturé 4000
appels par jour et quand on a la chance
de décrocher une place ces femmes ils
ont la peur au ventre parce que dans ces
centres tout le monde se mélange les
hommes et les femmes le jour fait un
petit peu plus facile
il ya des lieux qui les accueille pour
faire leurs papiers se reposer pour
comprendre une prendre une douche
mais là encore tout le monde se mélange
les hommes et les femmes
il ya très peu de lieux réservés pour
les femmes c'est des petites bulles
qu'elle apprécie vraiment pour laver
leurs vêtements c'est la même chose pas
d'endroit alors elle les jette
et pour se laver c'est encore une galère
la plupart vous aux bains douches
municipaux
c'est gratuit beaucoup de monde des
retraités des étudiants des sdf et
encore une fois tout le monde se mélange
les hommes et les femmes
pas de vestiaires spécifiques pas de
douche pas de toilettes pour les femmes
dans ce monde parallèle où les hommes
sont bien plus nombreux que les femmes
les femmes ont peur ou est l'égalité que
font les hommes politiques les pouvoirs
publics ou les chefs d'entreprise pour
ces femmes
moi en tout cas
depuis je les ai rencontrés je pense à
elle tous les matins quand je me mets de
la crème ou du parfum je me dis que j'ai
de la chance
elles m'ont appris à relativiser elles
m'ont donné de l'énergie
elles m'ont fait rire elle m'a offert
des cadeaux improbable
les bottes en cuir une pince à épiler un
foie gras
certaines sont sortis d'autres y sont
encore j'ai organisé une projection pour
leur montrer mon film
elles étaient toutes là pour se voir sur
grand écran elle avait peur à la fin
l'une d'entre elles est venu me voir et
m'a dit je me suis trouvée belle merci
j'avais gagné une partie du combat
pourquoi pas vous
[Musique]
et face on est arrivé j'ai dormi toute
petite amie dans le bus d'une station
c'est parti le réveil à 5h me fait
sortir du bus lors de sortir
m
il
on
m
[Musique]
essayez les hôpitaux mais dans les
hôpitaux ils sont un peu moins
sympathiques on sait pas pourquoi il
accepte très peu
[Musique]
on
avec l'eau
oui
[Musique]
hop je m'appelle petit crémant
par contre comme je mange pas bien je
perds beaucoup de cheveux le fait de mal
manger de voir s'allonger des fois je
mange toujours mais de la merde quoi ont
besoin j'ai perdu 6 kilos dupuis comme
dans les belles faut pas ma mère depuis
mai dernier donc ça fait c'est lui moi
c'est tout sept mois à peu près et mon
père un peu plus quoi penser quoi
l'avenir alors si vous dites je vais
bouger
oh non
vivre ensemble solidarité entraide
on entend souvent ces mêmes expressions
et pourtant on ose à peine regarder ces
femmes à terre chacun peut faire quelque
chose
certains ont déjà réagi ils ont ouvert
des hôtels spécifique pour ces femmes
d'autres ont créé des mobiles douche
dans des camping-cars continueront tant
dans l'eure la main et réveiller nos
consciences
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]